Dans des laboratoires de Grenoble, une équipe
d'historiens, de biomécaniciens, de physiologistes
et d'informaticiens s'embarquent pour une
aventure à travers le temps.
"Mission pour la science" est un aller simple jusqu'à l'une desdates les plus célèbres de l'histoire de France.
1515.
Ils vont rejoindre l'armée deFrançois 1er pour traverser
les Alpes, en route pour la mythique bataille de Marignan.
Une marche dont nous ne connoissons que les détailsrévélés par le roi dans une lettre à sa mère.
Ces explorateurs temporels vont devoir se mêler
aux troupes, et tenter de mesurer l'effort humain
dans des armures de plus de 40 kg.
Durant deux jours, ils vont quérir des réponses grâce à
l'archéologie expérimentale. Côtoyer des soldats du
XVIème siècle, et ne point languir pour atteindre
2641 mètres d'altitude. Seront-ils suffisamment
hardis pour venir à bout de leur expérience ?